the left is telling you that you need to
live the way they want to live and they
want things in your state to be
completely the way they want them and
you're saying no no your state should be
allowed to do what it wants and our
state should be allowed to do our thing
you're offering up a compromise instead
of telling blue states to live the way
you live you're saying let's agree to
disagree and they're saying no to you
that's the problem well that is true but
i'm also sometimes in favor of a
national divorce because
i kind of get
him started i get a little bit sick and
tired of this is why i'm like fighting
mtg is like the best man oh i i'm glad
you said of the fighting because you
paused and i was like you're gonna say
your husband
i i wanna clarify real quick like
it is just
the jokes you make the points you make
you you're fearless i really respect
that thank you well i i look we've had
politicians on the show i've met with
many politicians i typically can't stand
them because
they won't just say what you said like
you just fearlessly will say something
as
potent i suppose as sometimes in favor
of a national divorce is a powerful
thing to say well i think it's a lot
better than a war i don't i don't want
to ever see a war a civil war would be
awful
god i hope not but it seems that the
divide and the just the arguing and the
vitriol and the hate it just keeps
building and building and building
and and it it's really upsetting like
i've i've been we were in session all
week this week and it's nothing but
bitter fighting it's it's just constant
fighting on extremism and extreme issues
and i i just feel like if we're to this
point maybe we should consider that you
have your you know you have your blue
states and we have our red states and
and we can all maybe figure out how to
get along and talk again after we
separated
headline marjorie taylor green wants
civil war well they did that right watch
that
somebody's going to clip that well so i
know they did that already remember they
did there was
there was that big story where you said
you said something about
uh you know this could lead to a civil
war and they wrote marjorie taylor green
wants one oh no i never won a war right
never you want to know why all these uh
gung-ho you know people older than me
they're if they think that they're gonna
go fight in the civil war sorry old
out-of-shape people you aren't gonna be
the one doing it let me let you know who
it's gonna be it's gonna be my kids yeah
and i don't want that and and i think
that's wrong we want a good future for
our children yeah let me let me pull up
this post that you referenced earlier
from aoc i uh you sent it to me and then
i pulled up may 30th 2020.
this is just after uh the george floyd
incident it's uh the summer of love some
some of the worst riding we have ever
seen in this country some of the worst
riding we have seen uh the most damage
and and lost since the 50s
uh dozens of lives lost
aoc protesting safely what to wear
non-descript solid layer close uh uh
solid layer clothing heat resistant
gloves sorry what
gloves
goggles mask emergency contacts written
down tie your hair up don't bring things
you don't want to be right so they got
they got they got a knife nice turn your
cell phone off i mean why would you turn
your cell phone off if you're protesting
safely
well i actually i if if it was just the
what was the date
may 30th oh wow if it look
i'll tell you what the one thing that
really alarms me and it's the heat
resistant gloves me too that is that is
her basically saying get ready for
terrorism yeah now look if you talk
absolutely why would you wear heat
resistant gloves molotov cocktails okay
i mean it could have lighting a fire
tear gas canisters okay
tear gas can get hot when it's or or
cold i'm not sure which one is it is it
exothermic i don't know when when it's
um i think it i think it might get hot
i'm not sure
you're trying to find out if i'm
undercover antifa right now you're like
jamie which one is it well so when you
have your heat resistant gloves
compression is usually cold right but
i've heard people say hot so someone in
the chat can correct me about arson
wearing wearing insulating gloves is
literally about picking up tear gas and
throwing it or multiple cocktails or
starting fires but it says protesting
safely yeah okay well for you yeah to be
fair and this is not i've a list of
things you were talking about that i
would much rather defend than aoc right
now but could it also be which is
also bad
fire could be there this is how you
protect yourself not inciting wear these
gloves so you can make fire
not at us not at a safe protest not at a
peaceful protest also don't bring
anything you want to be arrested with
yeah
well look look look
i've seen people get wrongfully arrested
at protests and i've seen people get
arrested because the cops can't make a
determination on who's the one's
throwing the molotovs and so they'll
arrest everybody and then sort it out i
don't agree with it always sometimes
like
sometimes it's like okay i don't know i
don't know how you solve the problem but
telling someone i think it's good advice
to turn your cell phone off and turn off
face and touch id because the cop can
take your phone and hold up to your face
and then get into it yes and
fourth amendment i'm not a fan
the the one thing i'm like i want people
to protest safely i want them to have a
washcloth and snacks and stuff but they
tell you to bring water for drinking and
tear gas and to wear heat races and
gloves and i'm like sounds like y'all
are getting ready for some violence that
is not a safe protest that's not at
least that's not a protest i would want
to be involved in there's a saying i
wouldn't want to be near any of that the
left likes to post a meme where they say
to look who's starting a rod to look at
who is starting a riot look who came
dressed for the riot and they show riot
cops and then i'm just like uh-huh
uh-huh and you're also wearing masks
with heroes and gloves and showing up
with sunglasses and and bricks and bats
and stuff yeah you're you're both the
cops wouldn't be there wearing riot gear
if riders weren't showing up exactly
yeah but they do show up which creates a
precedent and now the police will show
up in riot gear regardless speaking of
aoc she was just arrested this week um
faking being handcuffed well well first
off they were like did she have her heat
resistant gloves when she was around she
did not oh she didn't read her own crap
she didn't she
well they were laying in the street they
were laying across the road the capitol
police asked them three times
congresswoman would you please get out
of the road you make it run over they
refused and so the police were escorting
them out but here's something you guys i
want everyone to know you can go to cuff
cuffthesquad.com
and send aoc or ilhan omar some
handcuffs oh my gosh really so for those
of you for those of us
they pretended to be handcuffed
they did they pretended so send her some
see there's our picture now also i want
to point out that it was like 93 degrees
at the time
it's very warm it isn't warm wearing a
lot 20 years and she doesn't look sweaty
they're both wearing dark clothing long
non-descript clothing yeah
and a green scarf uh for the group that
george soros funds
interesting yep that was out in the news
today
that it was an org it was an organized
effort with a george soros funded group
uh the green scarves yeah the green
scarf i forget the name of the group but
it's out in the news and um the whole
thing was organized so we
want them to have handcuffs because they
don't have any there when they're faking
their arrests
they need them
if they had their own they could have
taken the cuffs out put them on behind
their own backs their photos would have
been a lot better for their fundraising
emails
it would have been it would have been
seamless just fake blood smeared across
their face this one really this story
really pissed me off it is a raisin and
blatant attempt at they know the media
will protect them
aoc can go on colbert and make up
nonsense about the civil war did you see
that one
no she she
i don't watch stephen colbert you know i
respect it i i have to watch it because
it's like i'm trying to you know she
made an appearance i want to see what
happened right she said the craziest
thing ever and you know i think it was
sheamus who mentioned it was a total
chad move to go on national television
just lie like that he's not wrong but
she said she's like look at what
happened in the civil war the supreme
court was passing rulings that was
hindering lincoln's uh taking out the
confederacy taking on the supreme court
was hindering abraham lincoln like with
dred scott which said that black people
couldn't be citizen so what did abraham
lincoln do he passed he signed the
emancipation proclamation okay dred
scott happened like six was it four or
so years before lincoln became president
the confederacy did not take over the
supreme court the secession happened
before lincoln became president and the
emancipation proclamation was two years
after he became president and had no
effect whatsoever on dred scott but she
just lies the media doesn't do anything
about it so when she faked having
handcuffs on yep and the photos came out
with her hands behind her back and i saw
all the people on facebook and twitter
being like why are they cuffing her why
are they cuffing her i'm like what a
scumbag
i can't stand these people man everyone
should be angry because here's the deal
aoc she she comes from new york new york
has abortion
the the women in her district have full
access to abortion why is she laying in
the street and faking being arrested
ilhano moore ilhan omar they have
abortion in minnesota the women in her
district have full access to abortion i
mean it's fake outrage and that's the
thing it's like
if you
truly believe in your cause you should
be able to argue it without fake
publicity stunts and me as someone who
is pro-choice it's like this just makes
us look stupid i would so much rather
you have a conversation about why than a
publicity stunt for your instagram or
your tick tock or whatever i agree which
and i see we can agree that's going to
be the sound bite by the way they use
against me just you looking at me going
i agree and they're going to be canceled
i love you james i love you so much um
that's going to be the same yeah
i did it okay so i do uh he's going to
regret oh you're far no no
politics flows in one direction yeah if
a person on the left stand next stands
next to a person on the right it proves
the person on the left is right it's a
right winger yeah we should have a
picture of me and you and then it just
says she becomes progressive why can't
that happen
look at her going to the left if if you
i'll stand on the left and you stand on
100 yeah like just i'm i'm thinking of
the math right
if one person
stands next if a person if a progressive
stand next to a conservative people will
be like look at this they're hanging out
with conservatives their right wing but
what if it's one one liberal standing
next to two concer two conservatives oh
i'm sorry i'm sorry what if it's a
conservative standing next to two
liberals are both liberals now
conservative
or did the two liberals kidnap the
conservatives or
imagine one conservative guy in the
middle with five antifa around him and
has his arm around their shoulders are
they gonna say those antifa are all
right wing all of them no they're going
to say they kidnapped they kidnapped him
and no absolutely yeah antifa kidnapped
conservative
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time